on the night she died Olivia Pratt
Corbell was home in her pajamas with her
mum her older brother Ryan and sister
Chloe
Ryan Cabell told police he heard three
loud bangs from outside in the road the
next thing I heard was footsteps Across
The Landing it was Olivia she was
running downstairs screaming mum I'm
scared the jury heard him in a statement
say he saw Joseph knee slumped injured
in their hallway and a gunman outside
trying to force their way in what he
didn't realize in that moment was that
his little sister had been shot in the
chest hit by a bullet that had first
gone through their front door and her
mother Cheryl's hand he said my mum put
live in my arms and told me to keep
pressure on her chest her lips had gone
blue she wasn't even bleeding out for
the gunshot wound I knew it was over
the jury will also played the witness
statement of a woman who can't be named
for legal reasons but in it the woman
told the police that she had known
Thomas Cashman for a few years and at
times their relationship had been
intimate she told police that on the
night that Olivia was shot she was at
home asleep and woke up to Thomas
Cashman repeatedly tapping her on the
leg and asking her for clean clothes
I could just hear him saying give me a
pair of pants she told the police he was
very nervous do you know what I mean
I've never seen him like that that's why
I felt like there was something wrong
she said she heard Thomas Cashman who's
34 say the name Joey knee and later say
I've done Joey she continued I asked him
where he's been before and he just said
he went to drop the bits off before he
came to my house asked what she thought
he meant by bits she said I honestly
believe it was the guns yeah I do
believe it was the guns
Thomas Cashman denies going to this
witness's house and all of the charges
against him including the attempted
murder of Joseph knee and the murder of
nine-year-old Olivia
Katrina fertazzi Sky News Manchester